the golden session Hall at the Royal
Swedish Academy filled up early as the
Science World waited to hear who would
be awarded chemistry's Greatest Prize
and nine hundred thousand dollars as it
turned out three would become Nobel
laureates Denmark's Morton meldal and
Americans Carolyn bertozi and Barry
sharpless
they received the prize for
the development of Click chemistry and
bio orthogonal chemistry
sharpless joins an elite group of five
to have won two Nobel prizes the first
coming in 2001. now it's his discovery
of a way of joining molecules together
that has helped him and his fellow
chemists to the 2022 award the work of
these three laureates sparked a
revolution in their field and it started
with a little click
like this
click chemistry is now being tested in
targeted cancer Pharmaceuticals and
already has a host of uses in health
Agriculture and Industry it works pretty
much like two buckles that you snap
together and you can attach to these
buckles different types of belts
essentially and then once you have a
number of building blocks you can you
can build almost anything
who made that possible in living
organisms as she pioneered bio
orthogonal chemistry
stunning shark right I mean it was the
uh the chair of the Nobel Prize
committee and his colleagues in the
background called to say congratulations
I thought you know it's like a weird
surreal
moment
bertozi also helps to somewhat write the
gender imbalance she's only the eighth
female chemistry Laureate alongside 182
men
former president of the royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences Christina Mulberry
believes inequality is being reduced
the other Commerce sector please
there will be more winners because more
women are becoming professors and making
breakthroughs no one can ever think they
were chosen because they are a woman
what we can do is encourage more to be
nominated because without that you can't
win a Nobel Prize
click chemistry and bio orthogonal
chemistry involve processes far beyond
the reach of human Vision the Nobel
award has at least put them and their
Pioneers finally in the public eye
Polaris Al Jazeera Stockholm